- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan here
for our daily livestream.
And just as a reminder of what this is
for some of you all who might be new is
as the school closures have
kind of rolled out around
not just the country but the world,
we realized that there is a lot of
demand for folks to also feel a little bit
more connected to each other.
And there's just a lot of
information going around
around the school closures,
there's a lot of materials
that we're putting out,
and it would be nice to have a place
where we can all connect,
at least once a day,
to make sure that we can
answer each other's questions,
and get some of those announcements out.
And so we're calling this something
of a national or a global homeroom.
And the whole point is
to ask your questions.
I have fellow team members who are looking
at the questions you're asking on Facebook
and in YouTube and on Twitter,
and we will get to them.
We're also going to be
bringing in some guests.
Now, one thing I do like to remind folks
is Khan Academy is a not-for-profit.
We are funded by philanthropic donations.
It costs a lot more money
than you might think
to create a platform that can serve
hundreds of millions of people.
Khan Academy is much more than me.
We're over 200 full-time employees,
thousands of volunteers.
Just our server costs are
many, many millions of dollars
and it looks like our traffic,
because of school closures is two X
and approaching three X of
what it normally would be.
So we definitely need your help.
I want to do a quick thank you
to some corporate partners
who have stepped up
very quickly to help us
fund some of that gap,
although we need more help
from donations of all sizes.
But special thanks to Bank of America,
AT&T, google.org, and Novartis,
who have been some of
the first to step up.
But we need more help
from you and from others.
Now, the focus of today's livestream
is actually how do we
help teachers and parents
get set up so that they
could help their students.
We've been talking about that
pretty much in every livestream so far.
I've talked about these
webinars that we've run
in the previous few weeks.
We've talked about some of
the resources we've put out
like the daily schedule.
All of this is available
if you just go to khanacademy.org.
You'll see on our homepage.
You'll also see a little a banner,
regardless of where you
are at khanacademy.org,
that will point to some
of these resources.
Teeter professional learning
at Khan Academy, Meaghan.
And so Meaghan will join us.
This will be a great chance,
and everyone can ask questions,
students can ask questions,
parents and teachers,
but especially we're gonna start
for some of the questions from parents
and teachers on how do you get set up,
how do you look at student dashboards,
what are best practices, things like that.
And as I wait for Meaghan to get on,
I will give a few more announcements.
Above and beyond this
livestream at Khan Academy,
we're trying to see what other
supports can we give you.
So yesterday was the
first time that we ran
a virtual classroom for algebra students.
These are students in
Algebra I or Algebra II,
and this was at 10 a.m. Pacific.
We did it yesterday, and we were able
to cover some examples, answer questions
about systems of equations.
Tomorrow we're going to be doing again,
you can see an example
of what it looks like.
We actually, it really
did feel like a classroom,
and I think there was
about a thousand students.
So we're all experimenting
with new things,
and I was able to answer a lot
of the student's questions.
Tomorrow we're gonna do it again.
We got a lotta positive feedback from it.
So on Thursday, at once
again 10:00 a.m. Pacific,
and tomorrow's topic is actually going
to be factoring and graphing quadratics.
It's not just me giving a lecture.
We're gonna give you a problem to work on,
for students to work on,
they're gonna be able
to fill out surveys on what
they think the answer is,
they're gonna be able to vote on questions
for me to answer, so we're
gonna try to make it feel
as much like a live, interactive
classroom as possible.
With that, I'd love to bring on Meaghan,
and we can start answering some questions.
Meaghan, are you there?
(laughs) Oh hey, Meaghan.
- Hi Sal, and hi everyone.
How are you?
- Good, good, good.
And maybe a good place to start,
I just talked about the Algebra I
and Algebra II virtual classrooms,
but we're also leading webinars
for teachers and parents.
If you could tell us a
little bit about those?
- Absolutely, Sal.
We know that this is a pretty chaotic time
for everyone, students, parents, teachers,
and we are trying to offer opportunities
for parents and teachers,
as well as students,
to ask their questions and find a space
where they can share some of the things
that are going through
their heads right now
and how we might be able
to best support them
through this transition.
And so over the past couple weeks,
we've had a couple of webinars
around getting started
on Khan Academy as both
a parent and a teacher,
and then we ran one last Friday on tips
for effective remote
teaching and learning.
The recordings for all
of those are available
on the site, along with
some supporting resources.
Coming up in the next couple of days,
this afternoon, we have
office hours, again,
for teachers to get
their questions answered
by some of our ambassadors,
our really exceptional,
you know,
and then we have another webinar tomorrow
from one of our ambassadors talking about
some of the best ways for teachers
to get effective results
using Khan Academy.
And keep an eye out.
We'll be looking to add another
parent webinar next week
to help parents get started
with both Khan Academy
and Khan Academy Kids.
- Awesome. Thanks, Meaghan.
And maybe just a starting question
that we've gotten many versions
of what I'm about to ask you.
But a lot of teachers and parents
are just feeling a little overwhelmed.
Schools closed with not a lotta notice,
not a lotta planning,
this is a new frontier
for all of us.
For speaking to a teacher, and
to some degree a parent now
who is feeling overwhelmed,
how should they even think
about remote learning,
and what steps might they wanna take?
- I think that's a really key point, Sal,
is that a lot of people
are feeling overwhelmed,
and there wasn't a lotta
time for preparation.
And teachers, in
particulars, are preparers.
As a classroom teacher for nine years,
I couldn't imagine the
shock of transitioning
from being in a classroom
brick and mortar space
with my students to jumping
fully remote so quickly.
I think one thing that I've
heard from a lot of teachers
and a lot of parents
is take a deep breath.
It's not the expectation
that you are going
to cover everything you would cover
in your classroom right now.
It's really important to cut yourself
and your students some slack,
and just know that the fact
that you are taking the endeavor
of getting them actively learning
and focusing on some key
concepts is really great,
and that you're taking time to embrace
kind of the emotional impact for both you
as a parent or a teacher and your students
and building in some time
into your time with students
to be able to reflect with them,
and you know, take some time as you shared
in some of the schedules,
take some time to reflect on
what's going on right now,
and incorporate that into
the learning experience.
I'd say the other piece
that I would really, really
focus on is communication.
I fear sometimes that working remotely
with students and teachers
gives the illusion
that there's less to need to communicate.
But in fact, we really need
more communication right now
and taking the time to either connect live
with students or send
a message to students,
you know, finding opportunities
to create that human
connection even if you're not
in the same physical space
is so important right now.
- I'm getting a question
here from Debbie Charlton
who's actually one of the Khan Academy
teacher ambassadors, and Debbie's asking--
- Yeah!
- You know Debbie, "How
can you assign content
"to specific students based
on what they have not worked
"on yet but others may have?"
So we have this situation
where, I guess always
kids might be at different levels,
might be working at different things,
and to some degree we support that,
but how does a teacher maybe assign that,
or should they assign that?
How do you think about that?
- Yeah, I think it's a good question
that we think about not just in this time
but especially now where you
have the additional challenge
of not being able to see that student.
I think what is really
great about Khan Academy
is the ability to assign
these broad mastery goals.
When we think about what
are the students trying
to accomplish for the year.
Are they trying to, you
know, work on Algebra I?
Are they trying to
complete third grade math
or maybe high school biology?
Our mastery extends beyond math.
And so I think starting
with that mastery goal,
which allows students to
work at their own time
and pace, and helps them
identify areas of opportunity.
And we have some resources
right on the site,
right from that banner when
you get to Khan Academy,
that will connect you and
how to set up a mastery goal.
So any teacher could leverage that
as a really good starting point,
and then once you're able
to see students progress,
and we see maybe after
three to five sessions
on working towards that master goal,
the teacher reporting will allow teachers
to identify growth opportunities,
so skills that students might
need additional support with,
and from there, there's an assign button,
and teachers can import
the individual students,
small groups of students,
or the entire class
with aligned exercise to identify
and support learning in that gap area.
So the short version is
assign a mastery goal,
and use the data to make
supporting assignments.
And we have, again, we
have some resources right
on our website that walk
teachers through this,
and some specifically to support
in that remote learning situation.
- And we have another
kind of related question,
also from Debbie, which is a
question I think many teachers
are asking which is how does
it work with Google Classroom?
We just talked about assignments
and to what degree should you
when kids are at different levels,
but what support or integration
do we or don't we have
with Google Classroom?
Or how would you use it?
- It's a good question.
We do integrate with Google Classroom,
and the best thing about that is that
we know a lot of teachers are establishing
their classrooms on Khan Academy now,
and (chuckles) as a
teacher, I can empathize
with the setup and fostering and getting
to norms with students.
If your students are already comfortable
with Google Classroom, you
can connect Google Classroom
directly to Khan Academy.
You don't have to add a new roster,
you don't have to create a new class,
as you set up your class there's an option
that says Connect with Google Classroom,
and it will import your roster directly.
In a time where students
are already having
to learn so many new tools,
and we want them to focus, right,
more on learning the content
than learning new technology.
By integrating Khan Academy
with your Google Classroom account,
students can access that in the same way
they've already been using it.
So you're taking a step
of stress of off you
and off of your students.
- Awesome.
I know we're getting a
lotta questions here.
One of 'em, this is from Sono Gatelli.
"As a parent, where to
start on Khan Academy
"as a roadmap for seventh a grader?
"Are their live classes Khan
Academy's planning to offer?"
I could maybe take a
first stab at that one.
As many of y'all know,
we've published schedules
for students of different age categories,
and so we do have one that a
seventh grader would fall in.
I think one of the things
we are thinking about
is can we start, especially
now that it looks like
some of the school
closures might be longer
and maybe go through the summer,
we are thinking about
maybe we could create
some goals or learning plans for students,
but those haven't been released yet.
We're trying to do everything we can
with the resources we have.
On terms of live classes, these
livestreams, these webinars,
these classrooms we're doing,
we started with algebra.
This is really just an experiment.
We started the first one yesterday.
We're gonna do another one tomorrow,
and we're going to see where this goes,
what capabilities we have on
our side to do more and more,
but I don't wanna jump the gun on it
'cause we are very resource
constrained right now.
But I would love to figure out ways
to support middle school students as well.
Algebra we picked because
that's a major area
that's foundational for a lotta folks,
but obviously, so is middle
school math, pre-algebra,
and obviously, not just math.
There's other subjects as well
that might be interesting.
Let's see.
We have a question
from,
from Facebook.
So it says, actually it just got modified,
from Laura Hall.
"Our school wants us to filter everything
"through Google Classroom so it's more
"of a one-stop shop.
"I'd love to be able to link
their assignments straight
"to Google from Khan.
"Any chance that could become available?"
Well, that's essentially very similar
to what you had just answered.
And the simple answer is yes.
- While we're able to link
their rosters currently,
the assignments don't show up directly
in Google Classroom, when
we know that's a common ask
for teachers.
We've heard that even prior
to this remote learning transition,
and I know that there's
a lot going on right now,
and that would be a really
helpful piece for teachers.
We do find that the connecting
with Google Classroom
allows the roster to be, you know, brought
in really easily, and
that students can login
to Khan Academy simply by
using Google's single sign-on,
and they'll see their assignments
the moment they log in
right on their learner home page.
So that way students don't have
to go digging around for that.
So while it's not a direct connection
to posting the assignments
in Google Classroom,
it does really become
low-lift for the students.
- Great. Thanks, Meaghan.
So let's see.
There's a couple of questions here.
These go a little bit,
these are more student-facing questions,
but we could try to answer a couple
of these really quick.
Let's see. From YouTube,
Caras Alexander says,
"How is Khan Academy
helping out with AP exams?"
Well Caras, we've had content for many
of the core AP exams even
before this crisis hit,
AP calculus, AP stats, AP
biology, chemistry, physics,
micro, macro economics, CS principles,
American history, civics, and government.
I think I got all of them.
I might be, oh and art history.
I think I got all of 'em.
So we've always had that content
that you can learn at
your own time and pace,
use the unit test, use
the course challenges,
the mastery challenges to make sure
that you've really digested
a lot of that material,
and even before this
crisis hit, historically,
as we've gone into AP exams we have tried
to run some webinars and livestreams
for students at right when
they're trying to prepare.
And so we're going to try to explore
that type of thing for this year as well.
Let's see.
Other questions on YouTube.
Courageous Qbert says, "Is it okay for me
"to study physics in seventh grade?"
My two cents, yeah!
If you're ready to study
physics in seventh grade,
no one should stop you.
That's great!
You know, what I would say is
to do physics on Khan Academy.
We have the algebra based physics.
You should definitely know
the basics of algebra,
know the basics of quadratics,
things like parabolas,
factoring quadratics,
and know the basics of trigonometry,
things like sine, cosine, tangent.
If you know those things
you actually are ready
for physics, high school level physics.
If you don't know those
things, you actually could jump
in and learn those units,
those particular units,
and actually you'll
have the math background
to engage on the physics side.
Let's see. Other questions for
we have,
well, Astro Jaden on YouTube
is asking a pretty big question.
"What was the origin of Khan Academy?
"How did you come up with the idea
"of creating a nonprofit organization?"
I'll answer it as concisely as I can
'cause I've been known to
talk about this for (laughs)
a very long time.
Many of y'all know it started as a project
with my family members.
I kept thinking, "What
more tools could I make
"for my family members?"
It's eerily similar to
the situation we're in now
where we're just like,
"Okay, there's a big need.
"What tools can we create,
"and then how can we
make it serve the needs
"of more and more people?"
But this was back with me and one cousin
and then more, word got around my family
free tutoring was going on,
and I found myself with many folks.
And so I started writing the exercises
on Khan Academy, an early version.
That was what Khan Academy
was initially about,
and it was a friend that
recommended I make videos
to supplement those exercises,
and I thought that was just a silly idea.
As I often say, I said, "YouTube
is for cats playing piano."
(laughs) But I got over the
idea that it wasn't my idea,
gave it a shot, and that
took on a life of its own.
And then by 2009, 2010 there were hundreds
of thousands of people using it.
I had trouble focusing on my day job,
which was really being, I was an analyst
at an investment firm, and so I sat down
with my wife who said,
"Hey, maybe we should start
"this off as a nonprofit.
"Hopefully I'll find
people who can donate."
And I took the plunge.
The whole reason I wanted
to it as a not-for-profit,
I do live in Silicone Valley,
people were offering to fund
it as a for profit business,
and it just, you know, for this particular
role in society it felt
like the wrong thing to do.
There's nothing wrong for
for profit businesses,
but for something in
education where you don't
wanna make it based on who
has the ability to pay,
you wanna help level the playing field,
you wanna have universal access.
If someone wants to learn,
there should be no frictions to it.
That was the point.
We set up this mission,
free world class education
for anyone, anywhere,
and it was somewhat delusional (laughs)
10, 11 years ago for a guy operating
out of a walk-in closet,
but over the last 10 years with the help
of this really incredible
team at Khan Academy,
many, many thousands of
people who've donated
to this effort, and we need more help,
we've been able to make I think a bit
of a dent and really
scale to a lot of folks.
You know, I think this
whole school closure crisis
due to COVID-19 highlights,
I think, the importance
of us existing (laughs),
the work that this team
has been able to do,
and why it was important
that we're not-for-profit.
Because there's a lot going on at EdTech
and a lotta people doing
really great things,
but in this time of school
closures you need something
that is universally accessible,
and part of that is it has to be free,
and that's where we're fairly unique,
and you know, truly free.
So no shady stuff with
ads, no kind of free
but then there might be some
payment for better things,
no "we'll sell your data
type" of free, none of that,
truly free and not doing
anything shady with data.
That's important right now.
You have to have a breadth
and depth of subjects.
We have gone into many
subjects and in many areas
where there might not be a business model,
so other EdTech players
haven't gone there.
And so that's why we're able to go
from early learning through elementary,
middle, high school, core of college
in math, reading, writing, sciences, etc.
And yeah, it has to have
kind of more people.
It has to because of its nonprofit nature,
it brings more people to the effort.
That's why we're able to
have 40 translated versions
of Khan Academy, most of which are done
by volunteers around the world.
So thanks for the question.
I give the, I could talk more about it
if folks are interested.
So let's see.
Other questions that we're getting.
Let's see.
"If I'm using," and this is from Facebook,
Amy asks, "If I'm using Khan Academy
"for a high school senior
school year, what ground rules
"do I want to set?"
Meaghan, you wanna take a stab at that?
I could, I might have some ideas,
although I haven't raised
high school seniors just yet.
- (laughs) We had a couple of ideas
from the webinar the other
day that I think were,
you know, maybe something
teachers are comfortable with
but might not put into this framing
of remote learning.
Usually, at the beginning
of the year a teacher
will set classroom norms
for their students,
and what we find to be most effective
is including your students
in that conversation
about classroom norms.
You know, things like raising your hand,
or a process for when you're
gonna using Chromebooks
in the classroom.
The same type of things
apply to remote learning.
You have to reestablish
norms with your students
about what your expectations are
and what behaviors are,
you know, appropriate
for when you're having a
remote learning session.
And so if you're thinking about seniors,
and I taught high school
science so I can relate
to your seniors for sure,
I would think about taking time
to set learning norms and
remote classroom norms
with your seniors.
What are the best
practices for your students
and for your new classroom setup?
And then, by including your
students in that conversation,
they're more likely to
hold each other accountable
and follow those rules 'cause they felt
like they were a part of the process.
And so being able to establish those norms
for you and your students
makes everyone feel
a little bit more
comfortable in the space.
Sal, I'm sure you have something
to add onto that as well.
- No, I think that's exactly right.
You know, this is a time,
especially for high school seniors where,
I wrote about it in "One
World Schoolhouse" that a lot
of what we call teenage angst
I believe actually comes
from, in most of human history,
by the time someone was 13 or 14 years old
they were kind of proto adults,
and they were given
significant responsibility
in most of human history for other people,
for their clan, for their tribe.
And in modern society
for 13, 14, 15, you know,
teenagers, we don't give them a lot
of responsibility beyond themselves.
We treat them oftentimes like children,
and I think especially
for high school seniors,
as you mentioned, Meaghan, the more agency
and ownership we can
give, and it's authentic,
they feel like, oh, they
do have a voice in it,
they're setting ground
rules for themselves.
I have taught, you know,
we have a little lab school
downstairs from our offices,
and I've taught high school seniors.
I've actually found that when you say,
"Hey, what norms," you
know, if I told 'em,
"Hey, no one can do this,"
or, "You can't use chat
"this way," or, "You can't
talk while I'm talking,"
then they'll rebel.
But if I say, "What
norms do you wanna have,
"and how will you enforce it as a group?"
I've seen kids as young
as 12 or 13 step up
to that challenge and actually come up
with better (laughs) and
oftentimes stricter norms
that they're willing to enforce
than I would've put on them.
I think that's definitely
true of high school seniors,
and especially in this
time that everyone's
in their own walk-in closet, so to speak,
everyone's socially distanced,
it's even more important to rely
on their individual agency.
So that makes a ton of sense
what you said, Meaghan.
So let's see.
There's a question from Facebook by Judy.
"Can students retake quizzes and tests
"as many times as they want
"or can I put a limit to it?"
I'll take a first attempt at it.
The simple answer is yes,
they can take quizzes
and tests as many times as they want.
And you know, that's actually
an important principle
that we wanted at Khan Academy.
It actually would've been a lot easier
for us to just make
quizzes that, you know,
you take once and you're done,
and that's just your score.
But we're strong believers
in mastery learning,
that if you get an 80 percent on something
that shouldn't be like,
your permanent state
for the rest of your life,
that you're a C student
in factoring quadratics or photosynthesis,
that you should have as many attempts
as you need to take it.
But every time you take
it it's actually going
to be a different quiz.
So we've actually written
many, many, many items,
more than most people probably realize,
to be able to have that capability.
So we want students to say,
"Oh, I got a 70 percent that time.
"Let me take another attempt
"and see if I can improve my score.
"Or maybe I can go try to
learn it a little better
"and then try to improve my score."
I guess there might be situations,
although, yeah, in general
we favor kids trying
to take it as many times as possible.
Meaghan, any things to add to that?
- Sure, one thing I'll add
that teachers find useful,
while we do, and I would
absolutely agree with Sal,
that we do encourage students
to try and try again,
there's many people who will say failure,
or even if you don't
do well the first time,
does not mean failing.
It's just an opportunity to try again
and learn something more.
When we think about teachers though,
and they wanna see how
students are progressing,
if you choose to make
a quiz an assignment,
you do have the opportunity to look
at how students answered
questions on their first attempt
and their last attempt.
So if you wanna see how
they did do that first time
out the gate, you can look specifically
at those answers in our teacher reports
and then look at where they ended up.
So you can see their progress over time,
and if you wanted a snapshot
of their first attempt
you can have access to that data,
but we do wanna continue
to encourage students
to learn and grow.
And so, exactly what Sal
said, there is no mechanism
by which to limit the
attempts that they make,
but you as a teacher can
still see that information.
So in some cases it's
the best of both worlds.
- Thanks, Meaghan. That's super helpful.
Let's see. We have more questions here.
We have a question, this is from YouTube
by Algomarble Racer.
"Sal, how do you make
money from Khan Academy?
"It is nonprofit."
That's a good question and one we think
(laughs) about a lot.
So the simple answer, and for
those of you who don't know,
a lot of people say, "Well,
isn't Google nonprofit
"'cause it's free?"
Free and nonprofit don't
mean the same thing,
although Khan Academy
is both of those things.
A lot of for profit companies, and Google,
they've actually been great supporters
of Khan Academy, and actually
even in the early days
they were one of our first funders,
they're able to offer their services free,
but they make money in other ways
through ads or other types of things.
What makes a nonprofit
or for profit different
is Google is owned by shareholders.
They have owners of the company.
If you go and buy some
Google stock you are one
of those owners of Google.
Khan Academy has no ownership.
I have no ownership in Khan Academy,
or I have as much ownership
as anyone listening to us.
We all, it's a public good.
And the way that I and
the whole team here live
(laughs) is that we do get
salaries from Khan Academy,
and then that is governed by a board.
No one owns Khan Academy,
there's a board of directors.
The board is made up of,
some of those folks are representative
of some of the major donors
to Khan Academy, some
of them are other people
who are experts in education
or in other fields,
and they're the ones that govern.
They can hire or fire
me, they set my salary,
and similarly, they set the budget
for the whole organization.
So we take salaries.
Now, where does that money come from?
It comes from philanthropic
donations (laughs),
and you know, every time
I talk about the budget
of Khan Academy I get a little bit
of a cortisol boost,
(chuckles) a little stressed,
'cause it's a large budget,
but it's small compared
to the impact that it's having.
Khan Academy's budget is the budget
of a large high school.
It's about 60 million dollars a year,
but we impact, probably
this year, hundreds
of millions of students every year.
In past years we've had on the order
of 15, 16, 17, 18 million
students come every month,
and that's been growing,
and over the last couple of
weeks that's been growing
two X and three X.
And so we do need that support, we do need
those donations from
corporations, from individuals.
As small as you can see on
the screen is three dollars
makes a difference for us.
And so if you're in a position to benefit
from Khan Academy and support it
so that other people can
benefit from Khan Academy,
please, please do so.
We really appreciate that.
Other questions.
One from YouTube.
Teacher question, comes
from Katharine Curry.
"If we wanna supplement learning
"with Khan Academy with our own materials
"so students can see some of us,
"what is the best way
"to deliver our content electronically?"
I could throw out a few ideas,
and I'm curious what Meaghan thinks.
One thing that we've been encouraging
with the schedules,
especially in this time
of social distancing, is
kids can work asynchronously
on something like Khan Academy,
and it would be amazing
if teachers can organize
video conferences using
Hangout, using Skype,
you know,
Zoom, so that they can answer questions,
do things analogous to
what we've been doing
with some of these live
classrooms that we've been doing.
But obviously, you could
do it with your students.
There's also a world where
you can create materials
yourself at a whiteboard
or use a digital tablet
the way I have here at Khan
Academy to create videos.
I know my children's school is doing that.
And so there's a lot of
work that my kids are doing,
you know, like a writing assignment.
So their teacher is making a video,
putting it on their queue
using the Learning Management
Systems, so it could be Google Classroom
or something else, so
that the students know,
"Okay, here's my checklist for the day.
"Oh, I gotta watch a video by Mickey,"
one of my son's teachers.
He watches a video by Mickey,
Mickey says something about,
"How do you analyze certain forms of text?
"Here's the assignment," then he does it,
then he submits it on the LMS.
But it would be really
cool, what I've been seeing
some really incredible teachers doing
even at my own children's
school is they've been
having touchpoints roughly
at least once a day
with students so that
they can ask questions,
they can understand
how to navigate things.
Meaghan, any other ideas there?
- I would huge, hugely, hugely endorse
everything you just said.
Because as you mentioned,
right, in this time
of social distancing having
that social experience
is so much more vital to
student's lives every day.
They're used to being around each other
and leaning on their teacher
to share parts of their day
or to ask questions.
So I think everything you mentioned
is really wonderful, and if
teachers have the opportunity
I do like to recommend that,
along with the live experience,
make sure that it can be recorded.
Because we know that students just as much
as adults are struggling
with schedules right now,
so maybe they are responsible
for watching a younger sibling
or they only have access to
a device later on in the day,
so that if you are going to connect live,
try and make a recording
as well so that all
of your students have
access to that material.
The other piece I might recommend is
that if you are making
your own assignments
as well, if you can do them in something
like Google Docs or Google Slides,
and allow students to leave
comments for each other,
maybe one of those
reflection activities that,
you know, Sal, you've offered
in our daily schedules.
So that students can
leave really positive,
reinforcing comments for each other
so that they're still connecting beyond
just that one moment.
- That's a great idea.
I didn't even thought about that.
On our schedules we
suggested maybe journaling,
but there might be a
world where you do like,
collective journaling where
everyone has a little section,
and not only do you write yourself,
but you can see how everyone else's day is
and how they can think about
it and how they comment.
I love that idea, Meaghan.
So time flies when you're having fun.
(laughs) There's a lot of
really great questions here
that I wish I could get to,
but the good thing is
we're doing this every day.
So come back tomorrow 12 p.m Pacific Time,
3 p.m. Eastern, or whatever
time zone you might be in.
Thanks for joining.
Thanks, Meaghan, for joining.
As I say every day, these
livestreams are a way
for us to stay connected in this time
of social distancing,
and the silver lining
through this crisis that
we're all going through
is that we're all going
through this together.
I get a lotta energy by doing this,
I'm sure I speak for Meaghan
and the entire Khan Academy team.
It's really an honor
for us to be of service
in this time of need, and we
wanna do everything possible
for every teacher listening,
every parent listening,
every student listening to
make sure you feel supported
and you feel connected.
Thank you so much, and see you tomorrow.